hello everyone welcome to another
episode of play watch listen we are
trying to do these more regularly since
everyone is in quarantine to bring some
light into the wall to give people some
entertainment while they're stuck at
home disclosure before we get into this
episode that does mean that Mike Bethel
does not have a microphone so he might
sound a little bit off but for the most
part you were trying to do these every
Friday now if we can so welcome
we're gonna do our best I'm also
naturally joined by Austin wintry and
Troy Baker yeah it might just let Mike
Mike Mike has left us michaelis that
much of an intro like you have to make
an entrance Mike
I do also want to mention that tomorrow
morning there is a ps5 reveal stream we
are recording this before then because I
think Mike is flying back to the UK
potentially so missing our country Mike
[Laughter]
we do should we do a bunch of canned
like insert responses of like oh my god
I can't believe he did that
I love mocks honey that's all I'm gonna
say I love him I love him to bits every
time I've ever met or interviewed that
man is just just the greatest ever he's
so smart and so extremely like I want to
say even compassionate when he speaks
about okay I asked him for someone's
name once and he didn't remember and it
bothered him for the next 10 minutes I
love is you'll be like an industry
events like I know all the people here
you should be the most arrogant we were
at Dyess Awards and in Vegas and we're
all dolled up it's afterwards you know
the party that we go to and everyone's
having a drink in their hands and
they've had a few drinks in their hands
including my wife and we're sitting
there and mark Cerny
it but like you said just kind of just
chilling and walking across the room it
was like ha hey Mark you know just uh he
had given an award I came her to him
that night
and Pam was just feeling particularly
affable at that moment she's like hi is
she just reached out and she's like I
love your jacket and she was just like
touching his jacket and she gave him a
big hug and she's like who was that it's
like well was the main architect of the
ps4 and I'm sure the PS 5 this was
several years ago so we had just we had
just heard about the ps4 at that point
but yeah not necessarily the most
affectionate person so it was really he
took it all in strategies like there's a
stranger hugging me making him extremely
uncomfortable but that he would also be
extremely polite about it wonderful dude
some oxide in Pam's defense like yes you
you could be you could be doted on by a
worse person true story very very hard
to imagine being put off by Pam
everybody wins so yes we have no idea
what's actually happening with that
announcement but I did also want to
quickly mention I have been playing Doom
a tunnel and it is very good that was
today it is fantastic I can't stand the
platforming but outside of that very
good game have not yet played Animal
Crossing but I think those are like main
beats for this week in the games
industry
how did you feel about the previous doom
by comparison I love every single doom
except three doom one is one of my
favorite games ever like I absolutely
read all that game I love it to bits
I love the puzzle aspects of it it's
also one of the first games i remember
playing so i have a lot of nostalgia for
it but like exploring that those worlds
every single level being vastly
different like this one level where your
challenge is that you can't find enough
ammo and you have to figure out how to
do things with your hands and then the
next one you have tons of ammo but the
rooms teleport you to different
locations i feel like it's just so
consistently surprising and I love the
level design that's what I'm a sucker
for thisit's games that I love it's
always level design like I'm so
passionate about Dishonored and decided
to use the level design especially in
Tucson and to is just so so so good but
anyway yes love 2016 I think doom a
tunnel is better except for the
platforming but I don't know that
everyone's gonna feel that way some
people might be fine with it I just
don't like how it breaks up the pacing
my spot it feels very out of I don't
want to say out of Canada but that just
feels weird for for there to be
platforming in in a doom game that feels
strange to me yeah don't like go into
different levels and stuff because
that's obviously been a thing but true
platforming just feels well there's
always some element of like run run and
jump and hit this hit the narrow little
spot you know especially for secrets
right like that was always pretty light
but that's I never thought of that as
platforming traditional right we were
you a Wolfenstein person as well or
levels and such funny at the top of the
list for me v that my favorite
Wolfenstein was the one before the
reboot yeah it came every 60s well yeah
360 or ps3 I think both but it was that
era yeah I'm gonna be I'm trying to
member which one I played it on Wright's
ps3 at that point it's just the
narrative was super cool about it it was
super eerie because you're you're moving
around inside it wasn't Wolfenstein just
like Doom was always kind of like you're
in a corridor you're in a room you know
super claustrophobic and this brought
you outside to me which was super cool
but then a buddy might worked on the the
reboot he played BJ blaskowitz and I
think actually helped right and they got
people that were actual outwit survivors
to be part of the cast as if it was it
was a really cool I was just curious
because there was like it's a Pepsi coke
thing between Wolfenstein and doom a lot
of times people are like no no no I like
I think Wolfenstein was better like
they're kind of the same game actually
different reasons yeah me too and dual
of both but that said I didn't play the
original Wolfenstein I only played doom
back in the day I've played it since but
only played doom initially and I don't
know I think that the cool thing about
doom is I don't even know when they were
making it if they realized what they
were making
and how much it would influence
everything ever after that but it's it's
just one of the most important games
ever made probably and the fact that
that exists and it still holds up today
and I still frequently play in Doom one
maybe every month is a huge testament to
what they created it's so good I think
my favorite game as well right yeah what
do you mean dude was me an alien
really oh yeah
however I never heard that before
especially yeah it was meant to be
that's what I actually explains a love
like the design choices if you think all
that was meant to be as animals and then
like last minute as changing the exact
chronology bino started life as an alien
game I kind of to me nuts the nicest
thing about it is it's kind of it's like
it's what you said along it's kind of
some of the best games happen when game
designers and game developers like
solving a problem like having no license
anymore it's it's good stuff often
happens you know what I may have done
that because we played it on our show
and I think I remember running through a
little titty bit of yeah and for some
reason I just I would call it titty but
we just didn't turn man Tom the internet
dude got Emerson College I don't if I
told you guys this or not somewhat of a
tangent totally a tangent so Tom the
intern got here from Emerson College and
he emailed drew Lewis one of our
producers one of our like four of us
that run this thing and he was like hey
I'm moving to Los Angeles can I come be
an intern for you guys and he goes yeah
so with him like he saw us at PAX East
and was a fan of the show and then came
out and it's a huge funhouse fan as well
and then like within two weeks he was
being her little [ __ ] and and like it's
the most I speak of him as if he's gone
it was dead
but he just flew out Sunday but he was
just like the most down for whatever guy
and he I got a text from his like hey
dude I'm
been back to Boston I was like well
hopefully you know we get you back this
is just the you know a little hiatus for
you but yeah we lost Tommy the intern
but we could the reason why I bring that
up is because we started calling all the
little factoids about games we were
playing these little Tommy's titty bits
which is love alliteration that's very
cute
that was a well worthwhile tangent yeah
give it a solid seven Oh Tommy Tom the
intern
a lot I have a question for you and I'm
sorriest answer this if I may
speaking of like seminal games that like
you made the comment that like most even
Ken Levine said that most games are just
reskin of half-life 2 what other games
if you'd like doom Wolfenstein what
other games like that like could you do
a top 5 like V is where the games that
that launched a thousand titles like
what what what were for you what were
those games that were like that this is
the okay Ocarina of Time obviously there
are still games that just I mean I went
to the GDC talk for platinum y yo Katara
was talking about the fact that the Nier
automata map is the exact same size as
Ocarina of Time because they were like
what size should we make them like
what's a good map size and they're like
ocarina of time so they just made it the
same size and I feel like we I mean
Mario's the same but especially for
Ocarina of Time it's it's just Delta in
general really so many Japanese games
and Japanese devs are so inspired by
Zelda and it's it's really like thinking
about the fact that we don't even
necessarily have the game that is
inspiring the next generation of game
devs like we know ocarina of time but
the games industry is still so new that
maybe in 30 years as this completely new
thing that inspires everyone else
I think gears of wars is actually a
pretty important one for the cover
system that really blew that up and
obviously that's a lot more modern but
so many games have taken me l-like I
mean if if Rockstar wants to take
something from you then you've probably
done a pretty good job one that I really
appreciate which we saw more of is the
batman arkham combat system and that's
one that i'm like you can put that in
every game forever and i will
immediately want to play it okay and
mario naturally huge deal they're not a
few thought of them plumber italian
right Mike Ludo different distance hey
we have callbacks Tehran showdown what
about you I'm curious what would you say
to that question yeah I would I just see
the choice dressing I think I think I
throw in a vote for system shock just in
terms of the impact that hat I think you
need system shock and I kind of focus
specifically on systemic emergent
gameplay to get you to a lot of a lot of
modern game design a lot of modern like
you don't get so you obviously all the
immersive sins but also kind of I feel
like there's I feel like System Shock in
the games they inspires like your Deus
Ex or basically Looking Glass stuff that
gets you to open-world games I think
that gets you to a lot of Western RPG
design tropes I think that's one of
those ones that maybe is less or well
less well-known but like you can trace
back a lot of stuff to defend either
play System Shock now and he almost
feels cliche because you see everything
in it kind of ripped off so many times
so I guess I go for that or maybe Mel
Gere is one that for me is just a
massive meltia solid just was so
groundbreaking in terms of like I'll see
lot gameplay ideas they'll kind of fresh
and stealth really kind of blew up it
was I believe I'm right in saying thief
and Metal Gear so I came out saying yeah
the 98 or something like and having
those two games kind of trigger off the
stealth genre but it also of the big
thing with Metal Gear is I think a lot
of what we take for granted now in terms
of like quote-unquote cinematic
storytelling in games like aspiring to
telling movie stories and stories of
that kind of scale you can trace back to
Metal Gear I think that we all owe a lot
to that as well so those would be my two
systems shotgun lu-lu arson
yeah you actually you you I was gonna
it's funny I was the first game that
came to mind
it's funny how this is all we for all of
us is through the lens of what we play
it's as opposed to like a scholarly sort
of academic analysis of the industry at
large
I mean Alanna is probably the closest to
having that wide of a view just having
written about because she has white hair
played and yes just automatically gives
credentials as a PhD virtue of the hair
color thank you
no because I was going to say Dayo sex
but I think actually going one earlier
to System Shock is probably probably the
kindest no yeah you were you were into
it before anybody played system shock I
played too but I haven't played the
first one
- can you still play it now would it
I know that it's been a while I played
some interesting what was the tracks is
not only one of those Seminoles for me
was it I guess like you could go back to
mod so yes I always think of Ultima as
the as the one that kind of like oh yeah
like EverQuest was because of Ultima and
World of Warcraft it was in large part
because of EverQuest in my in my mind as
someone like that's that's what seemed
to be the the the sequence as someone
who was deep in it because I was a crazy
intense EverQuest player and and then
reached that threshold or I was like I
have no bandwidth for the rest of my
life so I just cold turkey just bailed
and then it was like a month later that
Wow launched and I it's like you know
what I can't even I can't even dip my
toes because I'll be I'll be in scuba
gear 38 Animas Guild Wars 2 and
Neverwinter my to go twos oh it's not a
good time because I also don't even play
them socially I just play them
completely fine with being by myself so
it's just grinding by myself by I did a
lot of that in uni and it was
was not a good call just I have to stop
playing them so the internet tells me
the first one is believed to have been
meridian and then Ultimo so you guys
spot off okay
the other the other hand is that by the
way for Katya what's a do though I
haven't heard of it the longest-running
one has been running for 19 years
[ __ ] [ __ ] Ardea I believe it's called
dragon's eye productions I've known of
it
good job yeah interesting niche niche
upon niche yeah I would the other thing
I was gonna chime in with was because my
my big favorite genre when it's like
especially growing up it has in so many
ways largely died out which was the
point-and-click adventure but the the
heyday of like LucasArts and sierra you
know you go back to the old LucasArts
like Monkey Island one loom maniac
mansion you know the mid to late 80s
LucasArts games and then like King's
Quest one and the other Roberta Williams
like all those kind of mid 80s in late
80s early 90s to me were like such the
blueprint of everything that I cared
about so much later sort of the the
grand culmination of which was a grim
fandago but then you have like obviously
the Monkey Island games and
full-throttle The Dig which to me was
like one of the most awesome games ever
made as was full throttle to be honest
but not always classic it's just so good
and and and but then it's like we that's
not really an active part of our gaming
conversation anymore the whole point and
click thing I mean obviously you know
Double Fine kind of gave it a little bit
of lifeblood and there's always Indies
that kind of have that influence but
it's not really a major part of the
industry anymore so it's like my answer
to that is sort of a thing that had a
predecessor but then also kind of died
well I mean like genetics for the mobile
industry that's still really popular on
mobile make a lot of money over there my
mom plays a ton of point-and-click maybe
to go to
what would be an example of never even
explored waiting to click like leading
oneness I believe is called the room or
the room game that's the one that is
they made it be a collection that's cool
yeah but that's a fool that's a puzzle
that in my I guess the distinction I
would draw is that I'm across the screen
yeah it's fine well that's the that well
that's the of course the old the I mean
the original ones that I liked where the
the parser interface where you had to
type everything I don't know parser
interface was the mouse click the before
that is where you literally type like
look around you know and and and it's
you know it's all and just massively
rudimentary like 16-color graphics where
you're like I think that's a tree and I
think that one single one like dark
pixel at the bottom is a hole so you
type you know low in hole bottom of tree
and it's like you found a key and it's
like what the [ __ ] ever thought to try
that I it's just but it was intuitive
back in those days he's coming back to
pass again so that would be I'd be fun
to do now what was the what was the game
that they played in big remember it was
like a it's like freeze wizard or use
hold no Zhul was text-based adventure
not Zul any of you guys played mystery
of time and space
no cavern of the evil wizard does
anything it uh it's it's online then
that tells me it's considered a graphic
adventure game but it's basically like a
point-and-click puzzle game that was
browser-based when I played it I believe
that I just got obsessed with it in high
school that I found extremely hot but
it's like you just start in this room
you don't know why you're there and you
have to figure out how to get out of the
room but it doesn't tell you anything
like I feel like it was really good but
I don't I never trust my teenage
judgment on things yeah space adventures
man those were the day hikers guide to
the galaxy was a great they brought it
back for an anniversary thing it
BBC did for that that was a browser
version text-based adventures were just
to me those were the blueprint for so
many games it was like oh yeah the game
that you can invent in your mind and
especially when you're tying it into a
franchise that if you had read the books
or if you had seen the movies or even
better at the movie movies were weird
but the the BBC production that they did
was was awesome to play starship Titanic
Troy
no what is the head bro oh you need to
play that that's that's Douglas Adams is
from the ground up text very well text
adventure graphic adventure hybrid
starship Titanic cool Star shaytanic the
voice that the Pythons voice acts in
there it's like if you're in save your
interview Douglas Adams that's a good
place for you to check out it's
completely Lincoln's life but the big
gimmick of it was that you basically all
talk to NPCs by typing so you it was
basically doing text parsing for
conversation and it was the mid 90s so
it's not perfect but like it's better
than you expect anyway that's my tip to
you
that's a heliumite I feel like um they
tried schedule I love Hitchhiker's Guide
and I got into it way too young like my
parents read it and so I started reading
it I was like nine ten when I started
reading that restaurant at the end of
the universe soloing thanks for all the
fish I mean all of that and what's great
is on my 42nd birthday which if you've
read the books you'll understand the
significance of their having a first
edition 84 in two weeks what I love you
because that would make you still older
than Elana 26 26 26 a lot yeah good girl
huh yep why she's looking at all my
virus sort of demographic breakdowns and
going
and then I'm immunocompromised I'm
terrified there's 26 ain't helping here
but hey trying to try to keep it
light-hearted so I didn't got one in the
Pro column then yes
the age is working for me and I've been
apparently to walk out during quarantine
I've been playing a bunch of video games
I've never tried using v-- off of
fitness before like naturally I've
gotten sweaty reviewing VR games before
but it's working incredibly well
naturally I'm loving beats a book
because beats a was the best but Watto
fur do you know job Stouffer he was the
community manager for telltale he's a
huge proponent for that and Joe Bloggs
oh yeah a lot of ways yeah Joe busy Joe
was a big dude oh yeah we saw each other
a dice you know I love job and he was a
huge proponent of yes runs a company now
right and it specifically focused on VR
like health healthy yeah I lost I lost
like three stone that's right but yeah
I'm was the thing I like really fast was
like I gotta stop going to the gym
that's such a big risk so I stopped and
I just started playing VR games and it's
it is really such a great way to walk
out because the best thing is you forget
slightly terrifying is you forget how
long you spend when you're in VO you
forget how long you're actually on to
that I remember the first video gamer
Evita one of the folks was a game called
Chronos which is from gunfire games
which I really love it's one of my
favorites it's very zealous Axl's esque
which is the most media person thing to
say but it is except with a fixed camera
they do this really cool thing in that
game where you stare at your character
third person they walk around and you
basically kind of control the camera
left to right and there are these
certain enemies that only move when you
are not looking at them so you can still
move your character around but you
cannot like if you look at these enemies
that perfectly still very what's the
Doctor Who the Angels but the minute
that you look your head away and you see
you can still control your character
even if they're off-screen and you can't
see them to try to move them into your
screen those things stop moving and you
can hear them and I thought that was
such a cool VI
terrifying but I really really loved it
so shout-out to Chronos
that's emergent too right because that's
100% based upon where of the position of
my head is rights like you said that's
that's driven entirely but my mechanics
that's cool yeah very cool super smart
funny that you say that about my
experience with most VR has always been
the same as you said but the flip where
I'll be playing in and I'll be like wow
that was that would what a quick hour
that was and then it's been three
minutes and I just like just like I'm
like sweating and exhausted and I'm and
I'm and I'm like stimulus overloaded and
it's been it's been literal seconds I
find them to be like casinos like with
Chronos the issue was I was reviewing it
and I had no concept of time and because
you have no natural light I thought it
had been a couple of hours and it was
like six and I was like oh I don't know
how I missed a meeting because I just
like no concept of what was happening to
me you take it off and it's dark outside
it's like when you leave the cinema and
you're just like oh god like it just
completely get lost in those worlds
which is a huge credit to only six hours
feels too long I don't think I'd be in
VR for six I say that well when you have
to review stuff like you got to get
through it as fast as you can really
hear you which I appreciate that by the
way as opposed to really yeah I play a
few minutes of it this is what I think
of the entire game it's a reviewer
that's what's called an awards jury hey
we're not disparaging BAFTAs getting
pushed and and everyone's going to the
to the little online model how do we
feel about that does that something when
we get into yeah I mean iga is doing
their awards online which is always one
of my favorites at GDC awards that just
general it's also online i i'm glad
they're still doing them i don't think
that you know for those particularly GDC
such an exclusive event anyway or was i
guess that most people can't afford to
or couldn't afford to get to san
francisco anyway obviously gtcys past
tense now that i think they should would
be happening right this second
would be we're in the midst of I think
the award ceremonies Wednesday night but
but we will already be published by the
time but that has it but I yeah I mean
it's such an exclusive event anyway that
you know pushing it to be it already is
pretty accessible but even more online I
don't see any downside to that really
it's what people get to see it did the
BAFTAs have a back-up plan or are they
just delaying know they're doing online
right yeah they're not actually pushing
they think they're just shifting it to
online that was a pretty exclusive event
too right I mean that it'd there's some
people that you could open it up to the
public we're gonna take it through a
lottery or whatever but the Oscars used
to be like a private dinner like it was
not obviously televised or anything else
it was just kind of like oh yeah just go
get your award it was a super downplayed
thing so I mean I I I kind of liked it
the the main purple we've talked about
this before our first one up but I think
the reason why I love awards show is
because it affords certain developers
the opportunity to make more games
because there's a qualitative thing that
they can now bring to the publisher and
so I see we did a good you give us more
money give us a game so I think it's
important that they not push or cancel
because those awards need to be given
now so that Studios some of those bonus
structures can be hit and people can get
back to work because that's what scares
me right now is Mike you know this
better than anybody is like if they're
not making something or if they're it's
there's some people they're gonna be
happy they get to slip a little bit
because they get more time to polish but
at some point then they exceed their
burn rate and they're gonna run out of
money and even if they're not like big
triple-a if they're an indie game or
whatever they're like we're out of money
and and we have to be able to ship this
game so that we can recoup right oh yeah
I'm acutely way yeah this situation it's
it's so yes of stuff like for in terms
of like us you know we have two or three
kind of things that are different stages
and every single one of them has been
impacted every single one of them one of
them has had you know
timing issues because of people's and
abilities travel what
sound like an Oklahoma firms other stuff
like one of them yes is is tight to some
other I'd be very thanks I miss reasons
but yeah it's every single project
that's obviously pales in comparison to
the actual real world kind of events are
taking place but yeah it's no but I
think it's working ever getting into it
does affect it does affect people's
income you know we're lucky in my team
specifically me and Alexander who I run
my studio with are super super paranoid
of times about money
I see his where the classy example of
like two kids who don't come from very
wealthy backgrounds so we're very tight
with money basically which has the
benefit to our team was like week I
think various my team and say we're fine
there's money in the bank
we're all people working even if we you
know even if things get our Labor's
where everyone gets paid it's all fine
that is a massive luxury and enormous
privilege but Bethel gain but the the
way you've set up every that you have no
office you're you're already a work from
home studio or by definition aren't you
so you're you're the most employees and
we're the most theoretically for the
problem problem is we work with a lot of
people you know that's the yes of course
I think people from the outside for easy
to think the games industry is lots of
individual islands but the reality is
we're all working with each other all
the time
there's twenty companies behind a game
you like and they're all impacted by
everyone else even companies that the
kind of the average gamer probably
thinks are in competition are still
relying on each other and still have
credit relationships and conversation
ten cents per mile of each other
they have relationships that go sorry
ten cent owns pubsey and fought night I
feel like that's just the biggest like
Pepsi
yeah it's all interconnected and that's
yeah but that is causing some problems
all it takes is bossy
bad situations to happen that's the
other things we're also international is
that I'm directly affected by events in
China and directly affected by events in
America and that's you know those kind
of things kind of slighted as well so
yeah it's tough time out there there's I
think the game companies the games
history's gonna be fine
a bigger level but there is definitely
like yeah please go bite I do quite a
lots of copies of dude please I'd be
great for all of us
yeah that's a great game to play this
week like it's very different it's
longer than I think any other doom game
it's 20-inch hours on nightmare it's
much longer because wow it's tough but I
did I did actually want to use this
episode to ask you guys what does III
being canceled mean to you individually
obviously for me it means a loss of a
tremendous amount of money that this is
obviously outside of like yes we
recognize that globally this is much
greater than III I'm very very
intentionally getting specifically
personal here but yeah it is for media
the most profitable week of the year for
every single one of those outlets IGN
made so much money during e3 every year
you get so much traffic during e3 every
single year I get the most followers on
every single platform which in theory
for me can translate directly into money
during e3 every single year so just just
looking at the paperwork is a loss of
yeah tons and tons of money but that
that's just the media side of it that's
really all media and theory loses a lot
of sponsors pull out because the traffic
is not there are not guaranteed in
theory you guys all have very different
Philly buddy do you think any any media
outlets like like I I'm on the board of
a charity and we would always do a big
fundraiser got we still do every year a
big fundraiser gala and for years and
years and years that gala was like 70%
of our annual income you know because
when we started out we were small and it
was like if we raised a hundred thousand
that night but we were a three hundred
thousand dollar charity you know that's
obviously a third that's a substantial
so if something required the
cancellation of that you know our burn
rate was such that that alone could
cause us to close our doors just like
that dude and do you think think this
could lead to layoffs in some for some
of the media companies yes because right
now is that tremendous I don't want to
give anyone idea was that much it's it
is absurd yeah I don't want to give
numbers away because I don't know if I'm
allowed to so I'm just not going to be
like I dunno IGN's traffic and and in
during that weekend it is so important
for them the site itself could run
solely on GTA wiki's but so much bigger
than that just just so cuz I'm unclear
maybe there's other people that are
listening that are unclear as well how
can you speak to how that translates to
money because maybe there's another
doesn't understand I don't fully
understand how hey if I'm there like if
I go to do like a keynote or find their
to do some press for a publisher they're
paying for that appearance maybe or it's
part of my overall deal that I'm there
to do part of the publicity and and hit
all the talking points but or do a
signing or whatever but what does that
mean for someone who is either a
freelance or independent journalist or
someone who is on staff for a company
like polygon IGN GamesRadar games UK
whoever that is there how does that
translate to money for that person and
more specifically money to that platform
so if I think I'm answering your
question correctly for like individual
journalists for freelancers especially
which is what I would have been doing
just during this year's e3 just none of
that work is there so they've just cut
it all
it's just naturally not happening it's
disappear it's where it's usually
everyone approaches it differently but
like my first e3 I went for the BBC I
was specifically working for this
program that was on BBC one and it was
about telling old people what the games
industry was which is actually really
fun it was stuff like I would line up to
play very specific games I believe
unravel was there that year so it was
like here's why this game is a big deal
here's why people are winding up for
three hours this what the games industry
is it was really fun so naturally all of
that stuff is gone for the media houses
specifically it's that sponsors pull out
because that's how they make all of
their money during e3 and also just the
traffic spikes around the news events
tremendous so it's I mean it's all ads
really but yeah I don't know how how
else did it question its sponsors
pulling out another one it's just like
IGN's ad revenue will go up because they
have 10 times more traffic that we can
norm
or whatever they're also the selling ad
spots on every single live stream and
IGN basically live streams 24/7 that
whole week I think it's even nine days
so they lose you know the ad who is on
the company whose ad was on the desk
because someone pays for that they have
these like panels on the back of the
stage that have ads on them those are
gone all of your mineral ads are gone
because they're not streaming 24/7
anymore so it's just tremendous deals
the biggest deals they have all year
just gone and presumably they've they've
made a big investment as well chasing
those deals so they've paid for the
venue they've paid for the stuff that
they've already paid start having III
meetings in November that's when we
start planning for e3 that's when we
stop planning who's gonna be on our live
show on what games they can talk to us
about because the e3 is all you really
care about every year and then there's
this little spike in November when Cod
comes out like a bunch of games come out
in November and everyone calls it review
season and that's when you're just
everyone is dying because it's so much
games to cover but III s the the money
make up a media Fisher but I feel like
you know has that been on the decline as
general like obviously certain major
publishers have been minimizing or
full-on just bailing from e3 and like
obviously Jeff Keeley's saying like I'm
out was a big story and like is there is
is it is it has the media you know take
the the income stream and all that has
that followed suit like is it one of
those things that everybody's having to
plan for the future and try to diversify
that or it's still basically like it's
still well worth the investment because
even with those sacrifices it's still
just so gigantic that it's obviously you
know for the short term at least very
viable PlayStation obviously wasn't at
e3 last year and I feel like a lot of
the community response to that I was
like III is dead it's not gonna work but
every media website that I know of
including our own streams at fun house
did better than they did the last year
so III online is getting bigger and
bigger every year and I think like we
can always forget that you forget that
like not everyone knows what III is so
every year there is this new wave of
gamers who are learning what III we were
getting into e3 yeah but I love that
definition of what e3 is is very much in
flux that's a fluid definition because
what e3 was even five years ago was a an
industry only event you must be okay now
press
so press kick okay you know what now
we're gonna start selling tickets and
now there's cosplayers at e3 so like
we've watched this very quickly changed
from e3 being to I'm going to sell my
game to Walmart because they're there
and they're the number one retailer for
video games in the US - or Game Stop
what else on that popped up as long as
it's not Amazon cuz they'll leak it
I think Walmart has to actually what a
Walmart is that plenty of time yeah it's
like they're putting up the the end caps
you know rage' - I think they were the
ones who did that they were leaked rage
- I think it was whoa Bob never almost
like rate that copyright someone has -
who's making rage - what but two weeks
later it was revealed Dennis Dennis pull
back the posters put it up on the
website
oops so I think that even III look I
don't know there's a lot of speculation
and I think that there's people saying
oh this was just them kind of cutting
their losses and using this as a
scapegoat that isn't well it doesn't
matter - to give credence to anything
along those lines it's purely
speculative and has no bearing on the
industry or whatever but to me that's an
interesting thing and why I wanted to
point out to you or to point out to
anybody listening is like this is how
everything is so connected that like we
are a this this industry and not only
just this industry but all of us are I
collect it we are a single organism that
just has tentacles everywhere I remember
when the strike the rider strike
happened there are people that were hung
on their horns in supporting people that
were writers but the same time they were
driving to restaurants that were closing
their doors because those doors like
we've all been to the smokehouse which
is right across
the Warner Brothers lot that restaurant
has survived because you ever been there
[Music]
no no that was bare lashes that was
something that was a great barbecue I
take a vegan at 2:00 to as many meat
Joy's as I can potatoes thank you the
smokehouse was it's in Austin points us
out to is that it's it's was the
namesake for George Clooney's production
company because that's it's right across
from the Warner Brothers lot and that's
where everybody from ER would go over to
and it's the kind of restaurant that
literally that he was built 47 and they
haven't changed anything including
legging staff yeah the staff does all
this guy is like Bela Lugosi is your
server and as they they it's a place
where you can either watch like a movie
deal get done or somebody get whacked
it's like it's it's just the most
old-school place but it's it's that
there were so many restaurants that
closed so many just mom-and-pop shops
that that closed took it because not
only are they fighting the war
brick-and-mortar with online and post
mates and everything else but when the
writers strike hit that was a
foundational part of their business
because people weren't going to work
because the industry closed down and so
what's so important I think like you
said and I have another question
followed up with Mike you said go by
many many copies of doom does that also
work for back catalog like if because
there's there's so many people go oh god
I'm a back catalog of games but if you
haven't bought it go buy that now does
that still benefit the publisher I'm
sure but is also still benefit the
developer and can that also help move
this industry forward by going back and
actually buying and playing through that
back out of luck or is it only to gas
yeah it's a tricky one because the
industry is yes to Lynn's connection
see there's lots of unfair relationships
built in to different parts of it I
might like what any within the industry
I imagine if you go and buy like an old
indie game right now didn't come out for
a publish it was when you go to their
state page it's just yes all right say
Thomas was alone on PC are you going buy
a copy of Thomas was learning on PC the
money you spend goes to my company
that's I think the only game we have
where that's the situation directly
right because then they're publishers
publishers do a really important job and
often like if you're buying a game the
publisher will get the money and if you
know a threshold has been crossed an
amount making those developer if not it
doesn't which is a again completely fair
and reasonable publishers are usually
the ones who put up lots and lots of
money in the first place so if if
they're in the situation I'm describing
that's because they're probably out of
pocket anyway the short answer is
honestly yes if you want to go and play
a game go buy a game that's gonna help
out the publisher it's gonna help
developer can also crucially help out
the publisher in more of a long-term way
which is publishers need money in their
pockets to invest in you games one of
the things I was tweeting about that I
just
I don't think gamers are completely
going to be conscious of is quite how
much business happens as events like GDC
in e3 I think we always think of e3 is a
press event you know is it's it's you
know you're seeing interviews with
developers you're seeing press
conferences you're seeing all that but
crucially it's when all of the for lack
of better language powerful people in
the games industry are all in one two
block radius a lot of business gets done
love a lot of deals are done and the
handshakes happen I was at e3 a couple
of years ago doing the John wick deal
without actually being at e3 but because
it was because oh yeah it was more than
a couple years ago three years ago
because it was in LA and because
everyone was in town so he could
literally just go and get everyone
around the table it was a stakeholder in
that thing happening was in town so you
can make business happen those things on
Apple would you be willing at or an
indie develop a little bit about what
those deals look like like so if we have
to do them at GDC and III what is what
is a deal to get a game made
look like what is that process so it can
be really complicated or really simple a
lot of people aren't you gonna tweet
about this did reply saying I can do a
deal in five minutes on skype cool great
good for you that is valid back and that
can happen like a deal there are
different kinds of deals as well by the
way is that who so a deal can be really
simple where it's just literally this is
now Shark Tank mic pitches you're
getting with it but there can be
basically you can be like I've got a
game idea here's a cool prototype I put
this pro I put a video this prototype on
Twitter equal five thousand likes please
give me some money so I can finish it
those bad deals are very straightforward
and the F publisher wants to put money
in then you'll negotiate a little bit
lawyers will all look at it come back
that's why nothing will happen remote
that's there's no reason that means a
physical placement the places where it
gets complicated is if there's anything
more complicated so for example if say
you were being given the opportunity to
direct in a franchise where the
franchise is owned by lots of different
people so enjoy makers of example
there's a film studio Lionsgate there's
the production company Thunder Road
there's all of the producers associated
with that there's the director of the
movie says the stars of the movies
there's lots of people who have opinions
and absolutely want to kind of feel you
out and get to know you sometimes I can
be done with Skype first time that
launched Redick was over Skype which was
the most surreal thing I've ever done
but a lot of the time yeah you need to
go and meet people who I'm in their own
kind of space and they get to know them
and stuff um but there the other thing
on the other side of this is if you're
an indie who's just starting at you
don't know anyone you know you don't
it's very very easy saying oh I could
Skype call someone Shuhei give me some
money yeah I can go and hold Shuhei
actually Whateley sure it's probably the
west coast you a is probably the most
accessible
[Music]
radiantly which but yeah people likes
you a the people who can do deals you
know those people the number of
situations and opportunities you can get
into it's like a GDC or at e3 where
you're just all around and I've had it
genuinely and this is this isn't I'm not
trying to show off but likely true I've
been a situation where I've been talking
to an ende they say kind of pitch you my
game I said I don't have any money to
give you but I'll have a look at your
game and then I'll play their game love
it and be at the pub with you hey later
in the day and be like hey you've got to
check out this game they're up in the
fifth floor and then I'll hear like two
days later I hope she ain't my I liked
it we're doing like those kind of
scenarios that's what you can't mirror
necessarily online a lot of people are
trying to and under I hope it kind of
works and I think you know there are
always open laughs there's also ways of
democratizing it like it's a big part of
this of course is well what about all
the devs who can't get to these events
and that's a really really valid
criticism of everything that you said
but yeah though there will be deals that
are not being done there will be issues
it's also enormous that say this but
it's also a year where theoretically
there's gonna be some hardware coming up
has a lot of factories are shut down
it's nuts and those kind of things are
going to be kicking in I'm expecting to
see we'll see we'll see but likewise the
you know big Triple A games this is
where crunch is a problem right crunch
is terrible on the best of occasions but
crunch during the crisis where where you
don't want people to be tired or have
their immune system shocked that's a
problem and I think we're definitely
we're going to see more game delaine's
we're seeing us start kicking in the
film industry the games I get the
impression maybe games companies are
waiting for the first person to delay so
they can all kind of - I don't think no
one wants to be the first to do it
because they know they'll get the
backlash by game two or three yeah I
have a friend at Disney who is okay with
me saying this but absolutely has to
remain anonymous he was saying the
reason that they delayed the launch of
Milan for as long as they did was not
Disney being selfish entirely it was
that if Disney acknowledged the series
the situation they then had to delay a
series of films and closed their parks
and closed a lot of studios and they
were actually worried about what that
would do to the stock market considering
they control like eight point seven
percent of the entertainment industry on
stocks so they were like if we as Disney
who I think publicly trade is point
Avista acknowledged what this is doing
then we kind of destroy everyone not
just us so they couldn't make a personal
choice they had to make it for the
entire entertainment industry so they
were very very hesitant to do that
earlier than they should because it just
hurt so many people financially so I
think you know all of these delays are a
lot more complicated than you would
think and I think we might have spoken
about it last time I do have a video on
my channel about it about how many
studios have assets that I made in China
and a lot of the I guess asset studios
were closed during the period of time
when China was on heavy quarantine but
that's a global thing there are
countries all over the world that make
sometimes it's odd sometimes its
character models I don't know if it's
everything really yeah I can actually I
can actually piggyback on that because I
was I'm in the unusual position of being
able to talk kind of openly about giant
squids game the pathless because they've
decided to be pretty transparent with
their duties of the hoodie you wearing
right now it's just like it's like my
work uniform we have a strict dress the
the I'm actually wearing a three-piece
suit but we also spotless on it yeah and
so I was in London at Abbey Road
recording for the score right before all
this hit and it was like well no but
that's the thing like that's that that
it's a roomful of musicians and it's
like I kept thinking holy [ __ ] what if
we had the ironic thing is that I was
tempted to push back the recording
because I was told I have a little bit
more time on the development schedule
than I originally thought I had but I
was already kind of past
this point of no return on the the sort
of train that it takes to get a session
like that together and so I decided to
just keep it and you know if the game
changes out from under my feet I can
make little edits and nips and tucks to
the music to match it but I'll have the
bones of what I need and so I decided to
keep it and if I had not done that then
I don't know how I would be finishing
the score now because it's like for the
foreseeable future I can't get an
orchestra together like there our
sessions are literally impossible and
I've seen networks of musician friends
of mine online who all are saying you
know you know I I play violin if anybody
needs just like a violin who can record
at home and but it's it's really
fundamentally not the same thing and yes
that's also very useful and I love that
there's a lot of people sharing contact
info to try to help keep freelance
musicians employed who have seen just an
overnight instant death of all their
work as you know musicians do session
like here in LA musicians do a lot of
session work and there's like all these
recording sessions that were cancelled
or postponed but then they also have
live gigs concerts you know the LA Phil
has completely shut down Hollywood Bowl
is you know gonna be a big question mark
because their season is still a few
months away but it's like are they gonna
is it are we gonna be in the clear by
then or not you know because that's a
that's an 18,000 seat venue that's like
the easiest thing to to justify shutting
down but that's also a huge income
stream for a lot of people and so it's
like the the music side of this I I
don't know I've I'm so freakin lucky
that this is falling in this narrow
crack between when I am needing to
gather around groups just organically
because I've had friends say well the
orchestra I was going to be recording in
you know Prague and the orchestra
cancelled and I have no backup plan and
like the game is supposed to be shipping
saying and I have no clue what to do
yeah I guess it's in that's an
interesting point is you just don't
realize how much it does influence
absolutely everyone in different ways
like a lot of the media outlets are
trying to record their shows remotely of
any of their like weekly podcasts or
whatever but
a lot of people who work for media
outlets don't have home set ups they
largely aren't streamers or content
creators or whatever they don't know how
that stuff works so I know a lot of
their shows are just not being made
because people don't have the set ups at
home to do that whereas the funhouse
we're really lucky about that that we
all know how to do that anyway
and James like had a really good thing
like he put that out as far as like
here's how worse things Healthe at fun
house he put that video up yesterday I
believe it was but like everybody has
the the studio that they need right here
in the in the pocket of your hand
whether you're Google Android or iPhone
and in tick tock polite of you to pay
lip service to my for you're the one
person so you're on this podcast I might
as well call it your product but I mean
everybody has the ability to that you
don't have to have the best camera or
lights and microphone mean mic Bethel's
on his air pods in his laptop it's it's
I know I sound there's a generation for
whom everything you're saying makes
perfect TV traditional media hate it
they hate things notice yeah yeah
and there are bid there he's big stuff
that these men to be happening who's not
happening because of this no because
because of the production scale of these
things that people just yeah people
don't know how to do this
reality TV was born out of the strike
because for yeah because they were like
we can't do scripted show fine [ __ ] it
this little show over here on NTV did
really good what if we did ten other
ones like that game shows started
popping up and all of a sudden is Who
Wants to Be a Millionaire all these
shows started popping up because we had
to go from I'm from scripted content to
unscripted content so it's it's one of
the best that the artists are the ones
who still subscribe to adapt or die
Bona ver his first record he did in a
cabin by himself with a shitty four
track
and that that per same thing Nick Drake
man pink moon was done on a four track
record at his apartment it's like I
don't and I'm telling myself this too
because I get equally frustrated when I
can't get whatever software to load that
is gonna be the best and and and then
you know biggest and best thing that's
gonna help me make music or or be able
to stream or do whatever it's like at
the end of the day especially right now
what people need is they need to connect
and they need to see people that they
know people that they like people that
they trust in front of a camera in front
of a lens whatever that lens may be
talking to them and offering them hope
and doing what they do people need to
see you Alana with a controller in your
hands and with headphones on and telling
us what you think about this game
telling us that you think it's shitty
and telling us what you think they could
have done better they need to know that
Mike Bethel is at Bethel games wherever
that may be making games you need to
know that Austin is sitting behind a
keyboard and making music or behind the
computer and making music they need to
see us doing that because that makes us
believe that it's all okay and that
we're gonna be okay and that just kind
of sucks right now and it's a little bit
weird but that we're gonna be okay
because if we don't have hope we don't
have anything
I think another step to that Troy
something I've seen you be tweeting
about which is part of me hopes that
this all happening encourages people to
be more creative I feel like there are
people who maybe never would have
considered opening up Ableton and trying
to make a song who this week might be
like maybe I'll do that or someone tries
to write fiction for the first time ever
or someone streams for the first time
ever because if people are stuck at home
and they have a little more time to do
that we could get some creatives out of
this who previously didn't have the
incentive to try to do that and it's
also you know so we can we can have we
can have people who have more time or
are encouraged to make cool stuff but
also have more people find them because
everyone is looking for more stuff to
entertain them with while they're stuck
at home and I don't know there's been
something very sweet about the even
increase I don't know if you guys have
seen it of people who've been doing what
do they call it just chatting streams
just with their friends whether they're
just intentionally not talking
anything negative it's like a drive
that's sort of been on twitch what
people like we're not talking about
what's happening we're just talking
about the TV show we watched and we're
trying to do that and it's just been
kind of sweet to get together and do
that stuff yeah
or the Italians that are quarantines you
know singing outside their windows and
even Trevor Noah taking the piss to make
a joke about it if you saw that or not
yeah I did that was hilarious the best
was in Italy in Barcelona the variation
on that where a guy put his piano on his
balcony and like a digital keyboard and
cranked the speakers and started playing
my heart will go on and like a block
over some dude leaned out of his window
with a saxophone and started playing
with them and I get the impression these
guys have never met before right and
there's like all these people up and
down the street just standing on their
balcony like in these little islands it
was a kind of take in Italy and then
just everyone on the street is just
singing along to whatever song is
playing it's like I love that so much
yeah you want me to see that stuff even
considering the situation experience
that is us in the [ __ ] that is us in a
situation of III I think it's great when
we stress test humanity because we
quickly identify the best and the worst
of us and I think that that's a
beautiful thing to realize what art has
come out of the worst times the best
music are still just broken hearted love
songs man and I think that there's once
we understand that these things are here
that there that's an opportunity for us
to learn it's an opportunity for us to
just be kind that's the thing that I've
loved seeing I go to my Gelson's and
I've seen more kindness than I've seen
in a long time because right now its
preternatural and people are choosing to
be to be kind and choosing to let people
go in front of them art Gelson's is
great i know everyone that works there
managers are awesome that's one of the
things that we do in our daily routine
so our daily routines got interrupted
because every day we go and like 6
o'clock and we go we walk into the
produce section and Cornelio is the guy
in produce and he sees traveller and
they both light up Cornelio comes over
to him travelers like Cornelio and he
goes woody let's go pick out a pair
pick out a pair together and Cornelia
cut some a pair so that traveller has a
pair to eat while we go shopping so our
day our routine has gotten interrupted
but what I love is that Gelson's said
across the board all of their Gelson's
is a local grocery store here in
Southern California mainly in Los
Angeles but they said the only people
that can just that can shop from the
hours of 7 a.m. which is when they open
to 8 a.m. are people who are 65 or older
because they were seeing a lot of people
they just really yeah it's freaking
awesome great thing that stuff is I'm
like this is we're gonna be ok
humanity's gonna be like you realize how
much we actually need each other when
stuff like this happens to there's no
like oh I really miss everyone
it's definitely shows you the value of
just human company I think for sure but
I did want to get very beautiful not
just for the information purposes how
has it affected you as a as an actor
what's funny is I saw jobs like Studios
send out a email to pretty much every
agents I just let you know like I wanted
to did a job for Disney and they're like
we sanitize the pop-filter we sanitize
the mic as well as we can without having
to actual do servicing of it we spray
Lysol in the room every surface is wiped
down with disinfectant stuff we
encourage you to bring your own
headphones which a lot of people
typically do I'm fortunate that I've got
pretty much the same headphones that
studios have I've got a couple of pairs
and so I started carrying my own
headphones I walked into Disney and
nobody was there except for the greeter
she's like hi I'm here because I can't
do my job from home and I walked in and
there was our engineer and her lovely
director and I did my stuff and I left
trying to have some fun but I've got
jobs that are lined up for next week
like Mike said there's still some stuff
that there's some jobs that have
happened and in just the right sweet
spot where they're not impacted they're
affected but they're not impacted and
everyone's just trying to I love that
frozen - got dropped early because
everyone's gonna be home it's it's stuff
like that that I want the industry to be
able to respond and go hey if nothing
else is
gives you an opportunity to catch up on
that show or play that game consume
media it's okay do it together don't
isolate call wait for Animal Crossing
for that reason like I'm much more of a
person than an animal crossing person
but the community that you get from
Animal Crossing is the thing that on
Friday I think it's gonna make a lot of
people happy jumping into each other's
town's stuff it's gonna be great oh wait
frozen to was what 90 days earlier
something was significantly earlier was
no no it was something was someone who
maybe that was that went the other way
everybody L like bond and everybody else
pushed and then then frozen tears like
bad word but it's the moratorium on it
right well Universal Universal made the
big headlines because they put the yeah
but they have movie that's they put
movies that are in theaters now like
their new Invisible Man thriller they
literally said we're moving this to
video on-demand like I think I think
iTunes starting on Friday or so and this
is a movie that was currently in
theaters I just thought it is two weeks
ago yeah yeah exactly yeah it's like
bullying the legal precedent breaking
like in the UK contractually yeah
theaters there's a reason that they
don't do this normally which is the the
movie studio basically gives the cinema
like X amount of time to have a and a
buffer and then home entertainment and
their buffer and then you know TV rights
or whatever and so please tell me mister
negotiation yeah I mean I really big
enough player obviously they can do
whatever they want but like it's it just
it's like there's bigger fish to fry
right now but I'm looking forward to
reading like the the article about the
link like the legal finagling and
negotiation that took place to gets I
mean if there is this cruise its they it
sucks for them so hopefully there's some
kind of compensation especially for like
smaller theaters that aren't chains it's
a big bomb I know the Alamo closed in LA
and I love going that we actually just
bought a friend a um for his birthday we
got him a season pass and he texted me
yesterday and was like thanks
music good point yeah it sucks all folks
who work in those kind of places right
that's the scary yeah that's how I am
yeah well we have this is this is it
sorry
troit what's really hard to bring up
yeah man I brought it to the top of the
intentionally but I was going to ask
that everyone who watches this there are
programs that you can donate to that is
the thing I would ask you to do in order
to help and I know very helpful service
in LA's Meals on Wheels basically people
who are intentionally going out of their
way to deliver food to the elderly the
homeless and also the disabled so
definitely look into those even you know
$5 a day you can get someone food that
they currently can't get at a grocery
store so consider doing that as your
gift to us in exchange for us trying to
give you this every week and I'm sure
we'll talk a little bit about
Playstation next week but I also was
gonna have everyone here talk about some
of their favorite games or games that
have gotten them through tough times I
have a really good story for that one so
we'll try and like compile a little a
little list for you all does anyone else
have any closing thoughts stay safe stay
healthy stay connected wash your hands
and make cool stuff and sharing yeah I
want to hear I want to hear new music
born of isolation yeah man be awesome
alright it's time for you moans come
back never left Mike it never left have
you seen this side pod I have no it's
still in my heart all right in lieu of
any technical troubles or any like major
things that delay the production we will
see you all next Friday